everybody this is Ross in today's video
I thought I'd give you guys a bit of a
seedling update show you guys how
they're doing what my plans are for
these seedlings here you can see
obviously now we've got them in the
greenhouse and then we'll show you guys
the cold frame because that's where
they're gonna be going I'm gonna be
planting them actually quite soon you
can see that the sugar snappies have
done exceptionally well I mean look how
beautiful they are I had pretty good
germination this year and then also you
can see over here that I have the the
broccoli and the Brussels sprouts
they're a bit lankier than I'd like
probably cuz of the lighting that we had
in inside the house when we we
germinated these but I figured because
we're getting you know this greenhouse
off to a head start this year
you know we've turned on the heater for
those of you guys who saw that video we
turned on the small space heater down
here in the greenhouse and that's
heating this we've also we took the the
tarp off the top
[Music]
so now we're letting some light come in
and you know it's heating up through the
day and it's also staying heated through
the night then also the fact that
there's just less stuff in here
then the normally is I have you know two
pots stacked high of fig trees but
normally we have like four or five so
there's almost like even double the
amount of trees in here or there's half
the amount of trees in here then there
normally is so I figure I have a lot of
room and I can actually do some seating
this year inside the greenhouse and I'm
like wow that's awesome I'm seeing a lot
of great benefits out of this obviously
you know it's a lot less work it's a lot
less hassle right and how to deal with
lights and the inside the house a lot to
do with making a mess inside the house
just obviously much better off doing it
this way I want to show you guys the
cold frame because we did beef it up a
lot of you guys had recommend it to me
when we showed you guys that video some
improvements and a lot of you were right
I made those improvements and it's
looking great
it's also really hot and really warm in
there because the greenhouse is actually
warming up pretty nicely but mostly
that's with the help of this heater but
you'd be surprised I think even without
the gear
how much during the day this cold frame
actually gets heated up and not only
that but the the soil is staying really
warm that's really been the key and I'm
able to transplant those those snap peas
and the broccoli and the brussel sprouts
as soon as they fill up those cells and
those trays I don't really see a you
know a time limit on all this I think
this thing's pretty much ready to go to
be planted into and you can see one of
the recommendations that some of you
guys had made was these kind of support
the the cold frame in the middle because
a lot of the water if it snows or if it
rains is gonna collect on top of this
and the plastic is gonna collapse and
actually believe it or not it did that I
think it was Rocco that recommended that
and one other person but it actually did
that literally the day after
and I was sick I couldn't come out here
and observe the thing and take care of
it
but you guys were right so I beefed it
up a bit hopefully that's enough I also
added some like support in the back here
to help lift the the plastic to give it
more of an angle and then I also want to
show you guys the insight here something
bare with me while I open this up we
also made an improvement on the inside
based off of another recommendation
which is obviously brilliant and
obviously how it should be but you can
see we've sort of wrapped the plastic
from the outside brought it on the
inside and then stapled it to the inside
of the frame
with a staple gun and then someone
recommended just get some trim and drill
the trim pressure-treated trim to the
plastic to give it some extra protection
that way this plastic isn't really
coming off the frame here or at least
it's quite difficult for it to come off
but you can obviously see I mean I've
been noticing quite a big difference in
just the last few days that I've had
this this cold frame altogether these
plants are really starting to take off
and it's really all in the soil
temperatures I put my hand in here touch
the ground even just a you know touching
it with my hand the difference is quite
extreme I have to get a thermometer to
know for sure but I would say it's a
good 10 to 15 degree difference and just
soil temperatures alone so I'm pretty
excited you know that's that's really
what's gonna happen here is that we've
got the seedlings in there you know
everything that I want to start this
year in this cold frame is gonna get
started it's off to a good start I'm
pretty happy about that it's also sort
of got me thinking about potentially
what else can I do in this greenhouse
I'm thinking about doing some citrus
trees bringing them from you know inside
the house putting them in the greenhouse
or even next year I can get myself a
couple loquats
I can get myself maybe a few more
tropical trees guys and really strongly
consider trying that again like the
citrus but even more tropical than that
and then having them fruit for me you
know earlier in the year is really the
goal things like the citrus can fruit
for me throughout the winter or even in
the spring and the very early spring
maybe even the loquat the loquats can do
that as well so I'd be interested to see
if I can do that in the house for most
of the winter and then bring them out
when I take the cover off the greenhouse
put the heater on I think it'd be a fun
and interesting experiment and I'm sure
we'd have pretty decent success so I
want to thank you guys here for watching
this one check out our blog on a fig
boss comm follow us on Facebook and
Instagram and hit that Bell button down
below to be notified for our new videos
take care everybody we'll see you soon